[Music]
what was it like to be a part of the
first delivery you know when I first
joined Amazon I never imagined being
part of a moment like that and it was
just so exciting to watch scout navigate
on the sidewalk for the first time and
really see the hard work and innovation
of our team come to life as you can
imagine a lot goes into creating an
entirely new way to get packages to
customers when we started this effort
like we do many of our projects right
here in Seattle for Scout we owned the
entire development from the hardware
itself to the software on the bot all
the way through to the backend
technology one of the first things in
developing Scout that we did was build a
hardware lab like this it allows
engineers like myself to build test and
redesign products in very short order
you've also developed our own software
lab soccer lab allows my developers the
opportunity to quickly test and iterate
on their software before we make
deliveries in the field it's hard to go
out in the real world and test the robot
so what we did was we brought the real
both inside I take the latest software
belt put it on the robot I just see how
it works my favorite part about working
on Amazon Scout is you just never get
bored there's just so much to learn I
think I actually have one of the coolest
jobs in the organization it could be a
little bit biased I get to drive the
software architecture for the device so
this is everything from software
integration to optimization the systems
and sensors are so important for Scout
because they're critical in navigating
in a neighborhood to deliver a package
to the customer we've learned an
experience so much in these labs
everything from the first time we saw
the robots moved to all the way to our
launch day it's just been an incredible
experience and I'm glad to have been a
small part of it
[Music]
over the past few months we've
accomplished a lot we put smiles on
thousands of customers faces and we're
excited to one day bring this to more
customers around the world when my
favorite part is seeing how excited
customers and even their pets are in
seeing scout for the first time and how
they've welcomed the delivery devices
into their communities there's a lot of
pride packed inside that little device
from the color the look and feel to the
lighting and even the speed at which
they move we've thought about the
customer every step of the way in five
years I'd like to see Scott delivering
ice cream to my niece and nephew talking
that is something that my son has
requested me he's like mom can you make
Amazon Scout talk to me so I think in
five years time to be pretty cool if we
actually could use Scouts who I deliver
to the North Pole
we might need different tires for that
we're excited to bring Scout to the rest
of the world and seeing the excitement
that it brings to customers when they
get their packages via scout for the
first time
[Music]